[Musique]
bienvenue ici sur cette plateforme a dit
yves factory iob à digiteo saclay la
plateforme additifs actuelle c'est une
plateforme ouverte qui va mutualiser les
moyens de la recherche ici sur le
plateau de saclay et les moyens de
l'industrie pour progresser ensemble sur
les nouvelles technologies en matière de
fabrication dit yves en matière de
matériaux en matière d'abus rytme en
matière de simulation et de réalisation
ce sont les grands domaines qui vont
tous nous concerner recherche et
industrie pour avancer ensemble ici en
région ile-de-france sur la fabrication
additive nous sommes ici à digiteo sakli
étaient au sec les vous êtes sur un site
du cea mais un site qui est ouvert vous
vous trouvez toutes les équipes du ces
en matière de contrôle non destructif le
contrôle c'était absolument important
dans la fabrication dit c'est vraiment
ce qui va permet de certifier des pièces
il ya un grand enjeu autour du contrôle
positif de la fabrication et yves
deuxième enjeu la simulation vous
pouvoir simuler finalement tous ces
nouveaux procédés de fabrication vous
avez aussi enfin et nous sommes heureux
de les accueillir les équipes du cetim
qui à l'occasion de la plateforme
additifs acteurs iob s'installent ici
sur le plateau de saclay à digiteo
saclay quelques exemples de pièces qui
sont réalisés par la plateforme additifs
acteurs iob ici vous avez une pièce on
structure la tis 1 c'est vraiment la
structure tout à fait typique tout à
fait caractéristique de la fabrication
d'études
l'additif factory iob va permettre
d'adresser des problématiques de la
fabrication additive métallique en
adressant une métallurgie très
spécifiques
on n'est pas sur la fonderie on n'est
pas sur la forge on est dans un domaine
tout nouveau qui nécessite encore
beaucoup de recherches pour aller plus
vite cet aspect vitesse est important
pour les grands groupes qui ont besoin
de rester toujours en avance dans leur
domaine la diva factory iob a également
accompagné le réseau de sous traitants
des des grands groupes dans leurs choix
techniques dans leur expérimentation
scientifique avant d'avoir à faire des
investissements très lourds
cette plateforme a dit factory homme
n'aurait pas vu le jour sans initiative
alliance industries du futur qui va
projeter ses ambitions au travers de la
plate forme pour aider notre industrie à
adopter ces nouvelles technologies
enfin cette plateforme n'aurait pas non
plus vu le jour sans le soutien décisif
est très important de la région
ile-de-france dans le cadre de son plan
smart industry qui met en avant ses
nouvelles technologies de fabrication et
qui soutient concrètement notre
opération